hello there chapter three of fortnite is
almost here a new beginning fast
approaches and if the changes in between
chapter one and chapter two is anything
to go by big things are coming very soon
here's a look at 20 things which could
be changing in the future ranging from
leaked updates which are inevitably
coming to the game things often
requested by the community and a few
zany ideas which might be crazy enough
to be possible we have a lot to get
through so if you've sat your butt down
for 10 minutes and slept in code adamaru
pretty please let's find out what the
future holds
new mechanics after four years of
building and shooting we're pretty good
at it right now it's almost second
nature to many of us this has led to
players wanting more more things to do
in each game chapter 2 has brought us
fishing and swimming and it looks like
chapter 3 is taking things even further
leakers have found evidence of a new
sliding mechanic soon to be unveiled
allowing us to shoot while sliding on
our knees dodging a head shot like
you're in the matrix will definitely
change up how people play other
mechanics have been hinted at too like
riding animals that gives us a use for
those annoying raptors that always
ruined my game and then they've been
testing a web shooter which leads
perfectly on to my next point it's time
for spider-man to arrive since the very
first marvel collaboration all we've
wanted is peter parker to join us if
that web slinging mechanic is being
worked on as a leak suggest then it's
almost certainly time for peter to show
up here's something you may not know
sony has a very tight hold on spider-man
and he is already signed to another
video game marvel's avengers and he
can't appear anywhere else until he
finally arrives there and guess what
happened this week spider-man finally
arrived in marvel's avengers it was a
surprisingly quiet announcement which to
me signals that spidey is ready to come
to fortnite next season alongside the
new movie which releases on december
15th here in the uk and the 17th around
the world so save up your v box and save
the date for spider-man's arrival
another addition during chapter 2 was
the vehicles the chopper didn't survive
long but the road vehicles are a
permanent fixture game files have
suggested that customization will be
added to vehicles in the near future
with both a battering ram and a weapon
mount looking very likely in chapter 3.
here's something i wasn't expecting a
large amount of people have asked for a
moving train to be on the next island
how epic would that be this would mimic
other games like gta and other battle
royales with warzone and apex legends
the most recognizable epic have
technically tested this with all the
cube rolling this season and if a train
comes to fortnite you all know we have
to get 100 players together and attempt
to stop that train speaking of apex
legends one customization in that game
allows players to choose a skydiving
emote these were and are very popular
with that community and could add much
needed variety to the fortnight battle
pass diving down to your drop spot while
back flipping or drinking tea could be
absolutely epic and this is a little
more closer to fruition as recently
superman was introduced with the first
unique diving animation
hey and where are the wraps for cars and
trucks we all have a desire to customize
our game and have everything exactly the
way we want it can you even remember a
time before back blings and weapon wraps
we can even wrap boats right now but for
some reason we still can't choose to
wrap the cars we drive there are a few
glitches like the exhaust pipes on the
flatbed truck cabs and warning creative
which lets us see entire vehicles decked
out in the colours and textures of our
wraps why isn't this officially in the
game yet it's great it already exists so
it must be coming to fortnite very soon
and that leads to another highly
requested piece of customization
individual battle bus skins the bus in
the sky will always be the iconic blue
to us but actually it's been many
different colors before we've had a
christmas theme a halloween theme a
birthday theme even naruto's headband
made an appearance oh no i said naruto
wrong someone's gonna get butthurt and
cancel me sumimasen anyway a custom
battle bus would make so many players
very happy and guess what it's already
being tested by the developers as leaks
in the past have shown that it's hidden
away in our locker screen already so
what are your bets that it's coming next
season custom battle buses
something quite serious now skill based
matchmaking many people are begging epic
to look into this as fortnite's skill
sealing is much higher than other battle
royales all down to the building
mechanic twitch streamer squatting dog
has a very interesting way to fix this
issue of being stranded in lobbies
filled with scrimmers and losing the
heart to play fortnite mr dawg puts
forward a new metric which not only
includes wins and kills but also
building skill this would mean if like
me you don't build too much we'd be
placed in lobbies with similar players
with a similar style those who prefer to
run and gun then build the taj mahal and
those who love to scream and be alone
forever will be paired with players who
enjoy that aspect of the game too so
therefore everyone would be happy
everyone feels more in control of their
own destiny and everyone plays more what
a classy solution eh all thanks to mr
dog much love everybody and mustache
there is actually another way to bridge
the skill gap with building it's
something epic is reportedly already
working on yet again smart builds this
will scare the hell out of all the
sweats around you but an alleged epic
insider has said quick builds are coming
in the future these consist of one-click
versions of something like a box and a
roof no skill needed no spinning around
on the spot one click and you're done
there's a smart tower too to add another
level to your build and even a smart
bridge just as you'd expect a ramp
connecting floor pieces to get over a
hazard whether these make it to the game
or not is uncertain but it's being
tested honestly what are your thoughts
on this macro builds for everyone will
that ruin fortnight or improve it let's
move on to changes in the game and in
particular a dynamic weather system this
theory is that by adding weather
patterns like rain thunder bright
sunshine and snow will give games a more
realistic feel at a base level weather
patterns will simply be a visual update
maybe with migrating goals that pass
overhead but should epic want to they
could go much deeper into the weather
system and make it a mechanic
extremely bright sunshine could cause
wooden builds to ignite thunderstorms
could electrify metal structures and
should natural disasters be included
like in battlefield entire build-offs
could be ripped to the ground in seconds
unlike everything else we've spoken
about there is no evidence that this is
in the works at all although the way
fire spreads in the game right now where
it passes from one tile to another uses
the same scripting needed to make this a
reality and didn't we already get a
hurricane-like effect in a recent live
event
not that far-fetched another hugely
requested change is actually something
we've already had the block people want
it back the block was a place to
showcase creative builds on the battle
royale island there was a giant tank one
week and the next it was some sort of 3d
art the block was a continually evolving
poi made by people in the community
in-game it didn't always go to plan with
sometimes structures unable to render
and it caused many issues on different
devices but that was two years ago
things have changed a lot since then and
fortnight has evolved what were your
thoughts on the block would you like to
see it return because i freaking love
that monstrosity
next a second chance mechanic
fortnite isn't afraid of taking ideas
from other games and straight up
stealing them and slapping them into
fortnite for example the reboot vans
wouldn't be here without apex legends
fortnite's closest competitor warzone on
the other hand uses another system to
let players rejoin the game if they die
too early this is the gulag two defeated
players fight off against one another to
be put straight back into the match a
second chance so to say epic has so far
decided not to implement this in
fortnite which is surprising as it's
celebrated by a large amount of the
community a second chance for players
who mess up their drop or can't find a
weapon and die in the first 30 seconds
yeah that's usually me and continuing
from this is it time to grow the lobbies
in fortnite how do you feel about 150
player lobbies we currently sit on 100
in each game battlefield 2042 has 128
and warzone sits on a whopping 150
with 75 of those able to rejoin the game
again so effectively 225 but on the flip
side apex legend only has 60 players in
fortnite at the moment two-thirds of the
lobby is dead and gone by the time the
second circle hits with on average 36
players surviving 10 minutes in each
game this can make it hard to find other
players to battle in the mid game period
so more players should mean more battles
is 150 player lobbies a good idea for
fortnite in chapter three how about 200
or would that be overkill
okay let's look at crossovers and i'll
share my data right away half of the
people i asked who wanted less
crossovers and half the people i asked
wanted more crossovers
i kind of understand both sides of the
argument but let's be honest here
collaborations and crossovers are here
to stay so let's look at a way to
improve crossovers and that's via poi
changes these looked to be a staple of
the new season when gotham arrived and
never left in chapter one and then we
had a full marvel season in chapter two
with countless areas of those worlds
brought into ours since then though this
has dropped off batman built a bat shed
on the fortnite island but within a
couple of weeks that was reverted again
now that the multiverse and omniverse is
established in fortnite law poi changes
would be perfect how about a minecraft
biome for example maybe a mako reactor
from final fantasy vii note to self when
editing this put a video of tifa here
because tifa is great i digress
crossover points of interest would keep
players returning to fortnite as nobody
could predict which part of the island
would change and how it would change
think back to pandora in chapter one the
art style changed in just one biome it
was phenomenal here's a suggestion i
wasn't expecting bring back loading
screens let me put that another way
loading screens that are relevant to the
story there are hundreds upon hundreds
of loading screens in fortnite some are
fan art some are renders with little
relevance to the island and some are key
to evolving a character and fleshing out
their history all without words for a
good example of this the entire story of
the visitor is told in weekly loading
screens from escaping the meteor to
finding and building a rocket and taking
us to a live event all told in still
images players who enjoy the lore of
fortnite would love these to return
drift's time on the island has been
presented by this method leading to a
better understanding of who he is so who
would have thought loading screens would
be so important oh do you remember this
one weapon charms concepts for fortnite
weapon charms have been around for years
so much so that other games have
released added them and sold millions to
their players whilst we wait in fortnite
when season seven of chapter two arrived
there was a teaser which looked to be a
weapon charm it wasn't it was another
back bling but the attention that got
caused epic to take note as we already
know fortnite's locker will be evolving
in chapter 3 to include brand new
elements making weapon charms a much
more realistic update later in chapter 3
imagine the tiny chair swinging from
your shotgun
i love this one the guided missile the
most requested vaulted item in fortnite
history well if you don't include the
zapatron this item has not been in the
game for years and it still remains
unaccessible and creative the guided
missile was introduced back in march
2018 and permanently vaulted in february
2019 we are fast approaching its third
anniversary of its removal and that
hasn't stopped any of us begging for its
return a rocket that can be manually
controlled and freely used to rocket
rider your friends it's something we
need to return epic so please in chapter
3 do the right thing here's something
completely left field players have
requested a kill camp to be introduced
into fortnight and potentially a player
of the game mechanic a killcam has been
a staple of the call of duty series for
years once we meet our demise the game
records that moment and shows you it
from your opponent's point of view this
is a great way to see how you lost the
fight and how to improve in future and
it's instant you'll see exactly what
happened without having to go back into
replay mode
and if you're an overwatch fan you'll
already be used to the second part of
that request a play of the game
following the match an epic moment would
be displayed for all to see like a mini
highlight reel for you and your buddies
to enjoy implementing that in fortnite
could be difficult as not many people
stick around to the end after being one
pumped by a dude in a box but the kill
cam though that would be the perfect
iteration from chapter two to chapter
three who's down for a kill cam next is
weekly map updates i'll be honest as a
map update guy i've had my work cut out
this year looking for map changes and
the impact of the story some have been
awesome and some have been watching a
chair shrink and grow again
and sometimes the map would only change
once a month those are really tough
times back in chapter one and in
particular season nine and x the map
continued to evolve at an amazing pace
every single week both big and small
updates could be seen we had gotham city
we had a slice of pandora and we watched
the seven build a new rocket which
played a huge part in the end of season
event heck we even saw the inhabitants
of the island building a mech ready for
the fight over the vault the updates in
2019 were amazing please epic games
bring back weekly updates that inspire
the community and now the most requested
update needed for chapter 3 creative 2.0
creative 2.0 has been coming for a very
long time now back in december 2018
creative was first announced with a
selection of creators invited to travel
to epic games and make some stuff at the
time it was revolutionary but now three
years later games like battlefield 2042
and the portal mode have taken things to
the next level thanks to epic games
unreal engine and its integration into
fortnite ui and also an entire year of
testing creative 2.0 is ready to go epic
spoke about this in 2020 and showcased
live edits in game that could be seen by
any player on any platform it was simply
mind-blowing and that was just the
beginning thanks to creator codes this
tool could realistically be a career
path for anyone out there so make sure
you try it when it inevitably releases
in fortnite chapter 3. so there we have
it 20 updates ideas and concepts coming
to fortnite in chapter three i'm adam
you're awesome and so are these guys
because they used my code this week
thank you so much for using code
adamarrow oh that guy that guy's my
favorite oh i like her she's great names
names are cool aren't they is anyone
still here
hi if you are
thanks for watching see ya